were speaking a few weeks ago
london had the fewest cases of covid in
the country
now we're the region with the largest
number of cases omicron is now the
dominant variant but over the last 24
hours
we've had 27 000 new cases of kobe those
are the ones that have been tested
and over the last week that figure is
above 70 000. i'm incredibly concerned
about the number of londoners with this
variant but also the impact
on our hospitals hospital admissions are
now going up as well
despite these kind of facilities the
latest figures show that something like
one in three londoners still hasn't even
had a first vaccine dose
how how has that happened you know
what's gone wrong well the brilliant
news is uh more than 15.4 million
vaccines have been given out in london
so 87 of those above the age of 16 have
had the vaccine those above the age of
40 94 have had both doses and because of
the brilliant work of the nhs partners
and others we've administered more than
2.5 million booster jazz which is really
important it's still the case though in
some pockets of uh london uh there are
black londoners uh there are muslim
londoners there are jewish londoners
there are eastern european londoners who
still have another vaccine so we're
reaching out to those communities with
respected message carriers trying to
answer any questions they've got
to explain why the vaccine is important
to make sure nobody is left behind and
we're so we're making sure that more
londoners are getting the first dose and
here's the good news over the course of
the last couple of days we've had
thousands and thousands of first doses
being given out we want to make sure no
one is left behind
when you speak to the people who run
hospitals in the capital
what are they saying to you about the
pressures they're facing at the moment
compared with what they've seen earlier
in the pandemic the big issue we have is
the number of londoners who have this
virus and that's leading to big issues
in relation to staff absences and the
ability of our public services to run at
the optimum levels i'm incredibly
worried about staff absences in the nhs
in the fire brigade in the police
service in our councils across london
that's why it's so so important for
everybody who's eligible to receive the
booster everybody should be better than
vaccines as well and as far as christmas
in the capital is concerned uh i mean
what's your message to businesses to
people who live here about how much of a
normal christmas they can expect with
just a few days to go well i've been on
a daily basis over the last weeks been
speaking to business owners
business managers
and the impact of the last couple weeks
has been devastating
theaters bars
restaurants live music
they've seen bookings cancelled and
they've plummeted in relation to
bookings being cancelled the footfall to
the west end is down hugely so retail
will suffer and that's why we're calling
on the government it's crucial the
government's going to provide a
financial package of measures grants 100
business rates relief more news in
relation to furlough if the government
doesn't you're going to see many many
businesses going bust and tens of
thousands of people losing their jobs
and just finally there is a partial tube
strike in london this weekend
lines being taken out or reduced service
inevitably creates more pressure on
other lines people may feel
uncomfortable in more crowded carriages
more crowded trains as a result what's
being done to stop that happening time
and time and time again so we've been
lobbying the government since july to
bring back the compulsory awareness face
mask backed up by enforcement i'm
pleased that a couple of weeks ago the
government did a u-turn we've now seen
increased compliance on public transport
more than 90 percent of communities are
doing the right thing a small number are
exempted it's really important you can't
keep your social distance you are a face
mask because one out of three people
who've got this virus won't show
symptoms it's one of the most unselfish
things that you can do
from tfl we're providing the maximum
amount of public trials that we can
tubes buses trams overground it's really
important though that we receive a
long-term deal from the government in
the absence of a long-term deal for tfl
we're going to have to reduce tube
services by almost 10
bus services by almost 20
and that will lead to
less public transport more congestion
more chances of this virus passing on
is irresponsible do you think to hold
the strike at this time
well the key thing for rmt to do is to
get back around the table with tfl to
resolve any differences that they have i
think strikes whenever they occur are a
sign of failure because i think always
disputes can be resolved amicably around
a table rather the need for strike
action